jamais victoire n'avait été aussi amerre
le 22 mai Orléan basse au chaud 1-0 mais
termine 18e du classement de Ligue 2 et
redescend en 3e division vous êtes
partis un tour de terrain petit tour de
terrain là de 3 minutes et on se
retrouve ici c'est parti allez go un
mois plus tard les orléannis sont de
retour à l'entraînement il y a eu les
vacances les espoirs d'un possible
maintien en Ligue 2 sur tapis vert en
raison des soucis financiers d'autres
clubs et la triste réalité l'US Orléan
est bel et bien en nationale pour au
moins un an on digère pas totalement
d'une descente après faut se remettre en
selle pour moi c'était ma première
descente en plus donc bon d'une d'une
ascension positive depuis la Division
d'Honneur jusqu'à la Ligue 2 redescend
au bout d'un an forcément ça fait mal
maintenant il y a une grosse volonté de
de remonter
directement ce projet d'une remontée
immédiate semble toutefois très
ambitieux le club vient de se séparer
d'une quinzaine de joueurs et présente
un budget modeste aux alentour de 3
millions et demi d'euros pour la saison
à
venir il faut s'attendre à un combat
c'est vrai que voilà il y a des clubs
qui seront mieux armés maintenant
l'année où on est monté en Ligue 2
c'était pas forcément l'année où on a eu
le plus de moyens par contre chacun
d'entre nous chaque joueur chaque
composante du club a mis a mis son son
je vais dire son esprit au service du
collectif et je pense que cette année il
faudra tout pris retrouver ce ce
dynamisme ce groupe pour pouvoir refaire
des bons résultats et jouer le haut
tableau du P pour l'instant Orléan a
fait signer six recrues dont un
défenseur central venu de première
division portugaise Enza Yamissi
derrière l'USO paraît suffisamment
stable c'est l'attaque qui suscite des
interrogations les réponses à partir du
vendredi 7 août